let's now prove the divergence theorem
which tells us that the flux across the
surface of a vector field and our vector
field we're going to think about is f so
the flux across that surface and i could
call that f dot n where n is the normal
vector of the surface and i can multiply
that times ds
so this
is equal to the triple integral summing
up
summing up throughout the volume of that
region
of that region summing up that volume of
the of the divergence of f
of the
divergence of f and we've done several
videos explaining the intuition here but
now we are actually going to prove it
and of course we're times each little
cube our each little differential cube
of volume and we're going to make an
assumption here we're going to assume
that we're dealing with a simple solid
region
simple
simple
solid
solid
region and what this means more formally
is that the region we're thinking about
can be a type 1 type 2 and type 3 region
i should say it is all of the three so
it is types
types 1
2
and three and there are videos that go
into what each of these regions are but
a lot of the basic shapes fall into this
simple solid region like a sphere or a
cylinder of some kind they can be types
1 type 2 and type 3.
and for a lot of situations that aren't
simple solid regions you can break them
up into simple solid regions but let's
just prove it for this case for this
case right over here so let's just
assume that our vector field f our
vector field f can be written as p which
is a function of x y and z
times i
plus q which is a function of x y and z
times j
plus
plus r which is a function of x y and z
times
times k
so let's think about what each of these
sides of the equation would come out to
be well first of all what is going to be
f dot n so let's think about that a
little bit
f dot n
f
dot n
f
dot n
is going to be equal to
this this component right over here
times n's i component plus this
component right over here times n's j
component plus this component here times
n's k component so we could write it as
this is could it could be written as p
times
p times or i'll just write p open
parenthesis
the dot product of i and n
i
i dotted n
i
dot dotted n and let me make sure i
write i as a
vector as a unit vector i want to be
clear what's going to happen right over
here if you take the dot product of i
and n you're just going to get the i
component the the the scaling factor of
the i component of the n normal vector
and we're just going to multiply that
times b so it's exactly so that's
essentially the product of the x
component so i guess you could say the
magnitude of the x components and then
to that we are going to add
q
times
j
j dotted with n
and once again when you dot j with n you
get the magnitude of the j component of
the of the normal vector right over
there
and then times
or plus i should say plus r
times k
dotted with n
k dotted with n this isn't how we
normally see it but i think it's
reasonable to say that this is actually
true this right over here is going to be
equal to p times the magnitude of the i
component of n's normal vector which is
exactly what we want in a dot product
this is the same thing for the j
component this is the same thing for the
k component
and you could try it out to find n is
equal to i don't know m times i plus n
times j plus o times k or something like
that and you'll see that this actually
does work out fine
so what would how can we simplify this
expression right up here well we can
rewrite this as
we can rewrite the left hand side as
so the surface integral of f
of f now let me write it multiple ways f
dot d s which is equal to the surface
integral
f the surface integral of f
dot n
times the scalar
ds is equal to
the double integral of the surface of
all of this business right over here is
equal to the double integral
over the surface of let me just copy and
paste that
of all of that business
so let me copy
and then let me paste
so
all of that
all of that business right over there i
just noticed that i forgot to put the
little unit vector symbol
little carrot
right over there put some parentheses
put some parentheses and then we are
left with our ds and then this all of
this can be rewritten as
this can be written as
the surface integral of p times this
business and i'll just do it in the same
color of p
times the dot product of i
n n
d s
plus the surface integral
of q
times the dot product of j and then
ds
plus
the surface integral
of r times the dot product of k and n i
forgot to carry k and n
d s so i just broke it up but we were
taking the integral of this sum and so i
just took it as i just rewrote it as the
sum of the integrals so that's the
left-hand side right over here
now let's think about the right-hand
side what is the divergence of f and
actually i'm going to take some space up
here what is the divergence of f well
the divergence of f based on this
expression of f is just going to be so
let me just write it over here real
small the divergence of f
is going to be the partial of p with
respect to let me just in a new color
it's because i'm using the yellow too
much
the divergence of f
the divergence of f is going to be the
partial of p with respect to x
plus the partial of q with respect to y
plus the partial of r plus the partial
of r with respect to z
so we can this second or this triple
integral right over here could be
written as the triple integral of the
partial of p with respect to x plus the
partial of q with respect to y plus the
partial of r with respect to z well this
thing once again instead instead of
writing it as the triple integral of
this sum we could write it as a sum of
triple integrals so this thing right
over here can be rewritten as the triple
integral
triple
integral over our three-dimensional
region actually let me copy and paste
that so i don't have to keep rewriting
it so let me
copy it
so it's going to be equal to the triple
integral of the partial of p
with respect to x
dv
plus
let me paste that again triple integral
of
the partial of q
with respect to y
dv
plus
once again triple integral
triple integral
of
the partial
the partial of r with respect to z
partial of r with respect to z d
v
so we've essentially restated restated
our our divergence theorem this is our
surface integral and the divergence
theorem says that this needs to be equal
to this business right over here we've
just written in a different way and so
what i'm going to do in order to prove
it is just show that each of these
corresponding terms are equal to each
other that these are equal to each other
that these
these are equal to each other
and that
let me do it in the and these are equal
to each other and in particular we're
going to focus the proof on this and
we're going to use the fact that our
region is a type 1 region it's a type 1
type 2 and type 3 but we're going to use
it the fact that it's a type 1 region to
prove that these two things are
equivalent and then you can use the fact
that it's also a type 2 and type 3
region
to make the exact same argument as to y
2 this is equal to this and why this is
equal to that